I wanted the whole feel of the film to
reflect what it must have felt like to
be going on these missions really put
the viewer into a totally immersive sort
of experience we both agreed that
anything that was emotionally involving
was usually always better on super 16
you think you're coming back we have
every intention of coming back but you
might not it feels more natural Wow
something like IMAX works really well
for scope it's all about making the
audience feel something it's trying to
pinpoint what kind of style is going to
best put the audience into the
characters shoes so leanness and i felt
that that was something we could really
sort of communicate on a gut level with
this really radical change in formats
it's hard to do a bigger jump in format
than from 16 millimeter to IMAX
here's to tranquility base here the
eagle has landed we know about his first
steps down the ladder but we don't know
what that would feel like from the point
of view of the person going down the
ladder actually seeing what he would be
seen and seen it in full IMAX taking
those first subsequent steps on the moon
we have been living with a lot of
emotions we shot that quite grainy and
gritty and especially inside the craft
we shot on super 16 and in order to give
the audience like the maximum contrast
to that IMAX felt very natural we had
always envisioned the moment of stepping
out into the moon like our Wizard of Oz
moment
when you open that hatch door and step
out on to the silent vast expanse of the
moon it's like a shot of adrenaline it's
almost like you've transported people to
this other world and I think that that
visual experience will really elevate
the personal stories that were telling
along the way I was asking Dave Scott
Neil's colleague on Gemini 8 played by
Chris Abbott in the movie but also an
astronaut who later walked on the moon
himself what his first steps on the moon
were like and he talked about never
feeling more awake in his life it's like
he could hear see smell taste everything
in a heightened way they made a point of
trying to explain just how different it
was visually we thought it was quite
interesting to shoot something so pure
and clean and monochromatic as the moon
surface with the black sky on that
large-format because it's so detailed so
you can see how clean it is there was a
clarity to the light there was a clarity
to the color that there was something
just heightened about it that sort of
trajectory became what the whole
sequence was about to me the jump from
16 the IMAX might help to recreate that
sensation but felt like it was sort of
crystalline clarity of imax especially
coming out of a grittier grainy or sort
of approach to the rest of the movie
would be the right sort of way to make
you feel that heightened level of
consciousness
hi here we go buddy clear tonight we
shoulda Neil Armstrong's descent down
the ladder panting mark we decided to
shoot the moon outdoors in a quarry that
has very much to call her and texture of
the real moon we were shooting with IMAX
cameras and we were shooting with lights
that leanness our cinematographer had
created to try and simulate sunlight and
the lenses were using are actually the
same lenses that they used on the moon
when they took the still photos it was
my first time shooting on IMAX film and
it was an amazing experience
the IMAX theater is really really great
to see this movie just because the
format changes from two 402 143 which
means that image goes from the normal
letterbox and opens up beneath your feet
you really get the sensation that you're
coming out onto the moon surface
and we shot on a lot of different
formats for this movie from 16
millimeter to 35 millimeter to perf and
3-perf all the way up to full IMAX to
really be able to taste that full range
you will want to see it on IMAX
[Music]
you
you